[Music]
something I was not expecting this
season was you versus Camille so much
too much girly hopefully she'll get the
message just shut your mouth [ __ ] I
never had any issues with Camille it was
just a very silly moment that
unfortunately happened and you know you
have to sort of pay the price afterwards
I feel bad there we go again what the
c-word the kind of felt like you're
you're such a moment came out of nowhere
it totally did okay nothing before that
there was no intention behind it it was
so out of left field that one would have
thought it may not have even made it
because there was nothing behind it but
here's to being a rookie you know you
realize of course it's gonna make it oh
yeah yeah so it was it was just that I
mean you know it was 110 degrees the
power was out I was there an hour and a
half before the other women I was with
my husband I'm at one of my best
friend's house you know I'm so relaxed
at Kyle's house and with them and I have
a lot of fun with the ladies you know
both on and off camera
so just maybe one too many tequila's
that night got it alcohol induced heat
induced moment of madness yes many many
hours later and then it was like what I
said what who read everyone's entitled
to a stupid once in a while but you
really abuse the privilege I'm here
what was the question honestly at this
point I really don't give two shits
about you were you surprised by the way
Camille took that and how she kept
talking about you confessional after
confessional after confessional it's not
nice when you hear the women having jabs
at you and you're in their confessionals
that's never Pleasant but I think to
some degree I can understand it
[Music]